managing services is complex especially
in multi-cloud environments
your application teams have an
increasing number of services
and hybrid deployments that they have to
manage as you scale
as the network information of instances
dynamically change
your applications must be able to
quickly find the most up-to-date
information
of your services these systems are
time-consuming and challenging to run
without a single place to publish
discover and connect all your services
which can lead to
increased complexity of management and
operations of your applications
and having to use your valuable
engineering team's time to manually
store
track and update resource name and
endpoint information
or make changes directly within the
application code
even with your best efforts these
systems can still fail
as your services grow customers want to
be able to take
a service centric rather than an
infrastructure-centric approach to
connecting services
we're here to help solve this pain point
with service directory from
google cloud service directory will
reduce the complexity of your
application deployment
allowing all of your services to be
understood across multi-cloud
environments
increasing the productivity of your
development teams
service directory helps consumers keep
track of their services as they scale
regardless of your environment as a
fully managed offering
service directory frees you from having
to install software
and manage instances as you scale you
won't have to worry about feature
upgrades or incompatible software
we will make sure it stays up and
running so you are not impacted
service directory will provide real-time
information
whether you have a few endpoints or
thousands
enabling you to register and resolve
them via dns
http and grpc define your services with
custom names and rich metadata
allowing you to group them while making
your endpoints easily understood by your
consumers and applications
increasing your application reachability
rich permissions ensures that only the
correct teams at your organization
will have the ability to update or look
up these services
so your application developers won't
have to worry about accidentally
impacting other teams
best part of all service directory is
deeply integrated with other google
services
helping you simplify your service
management and operations across
environments
learn more about how having a single
place to publish
discover and connect all your services
can benefit your business
at cloud.google.com